going on there citizens of the reject
Nation Greg here I'm going to play For
You The Last of Us video in just one
second but in case you did not already
catch our special announcement if you
live in the Los Angeles area or if
you're just visiting Sunday February
19th at nine o'clock P.M John can't be a
Christian harloff and I are joining
forces to do a Live show tickets have
been selling thank you to everyone who's
already bought a ticket it's going to be
a night of Comedy a bunch of laughs a
lot of quantumania and then who knows
whatever else but maybe I can set them
up to say something to get them canceled
I hope you're there what is happening
there citizens of the reject Nation we
are here to watch the fourth episode of
The Last of Us today how are you Andrew
I'm doing great I'm excited to see the
continued journey of Bill and Frank
ladies and gentlemen yes this is and the
real rejects to get the gamer reaction
non-game reaction with Tyra and John
which people are enjoying that'll go up
on Tuesday but in the meantime if you're
here please go ahead leave a like also
leave down below what you thought about
this episode that we have not yet seen
also subscribe click the notification
Bell get notified when our reaction for
the next episode of The Last of Us is up
here on this Channel full length
Reaction watch along as we sing with
your own copy of this series available
for our super sexy rejects over at our
patreon page we cover several things
over there exclusively with reaction
highlights and watch alongs including
and disclaimer we will make sure not to
talk about anything that would happen in
future episodes we will only talk about
what happens in this episode and how it
pertains to the game we will not spoil
anything possibly for the future we do
our best and I think I said everything
that needs to be said let's watch the
dang show now
you talking to me
it really is like a taxi driver's team
gas station the one from Terminator 2
right
yes nice how does that work that's when
liquid travels Against Gravity because
pressure you don't know I know it works
this is your fault then it doesn't
matter how much you push the envelope
it'll still be stationary
[Music]
volume two but we'll live next in
volume two look you get it two like t-o
what did the mermaid where did her math
class and algae bra
I stayed up all night wondering where
the sun went and then it dawned on me
here let's make you all nostalgic
Hank Williams it's actually before my
time
there we go see I was seen for scene
this is that's a grouse
right on the reading but it has some
interesting pictures
please get rid of it it's your horses I
want to see what all the fuss is about
why are all these Pages stuck together
[Laughter]
yes
great Recreation loved it
and they made it land just like it
Oh Yeah from the last episode you
mentioned Orbeez
wow these shots really capture the Grim
Beauty
all right that's enough for today
I thought we were getting into Logan
territory here
Chef Boyardee slow down this is slow
what am I even eating that is 20 year
old Chef Boyardee ravioli
this is too remote for infected anyway
people
dangerous people
smells kind of good
well that would be Frank's then
the rifle
I feel like it'd still be freezing with
no fire yeah they're on the East Coast
Joe what
can I ask you a serious question yeah
why did the Scarecrow get an award
because he was outstanding in his field
did you read this no that was such an
endearing moment go to sleep
I love that
he was really quick on his feet on that
one there's no way anyone knows we're
here right No One's Gonna find us
No One's Gonna find us
tick tock tick tock tick tock
let's set us their ass music I'd be
cradling that gun
[Music]
Terminator level of paranoia man
Cafe Joe loves it
oh what the [__] is that
you don't like coffee
seriously what those Starbucks in the
accusing used to tell it smells like
burnt [__] yes I was waiting for that
one what's his name
Who's name your brother
Tommy younger older younger why isn't he
with you
so we enlists in the Army ran out of
high school a few months later they ship
them off to Desert Storm
12 years later outbreak happens he
convinces me to join a group making
their way up to Boston which I did
foreign
meets Marlene she talks me to joining
the fireflies
save the world
of course last I heard he quit the
fireflies too so now he's on his own out
there and I gotta go get him
can't wait for you guys to reenact if he
doesn't There's Hope For The World why
bother going
on
we haven't seen the world so you don't
know keep going for family I'm not
family
[Music]
your cargo
what if you don't find them
how do you know I'm persistent
got up pretty early if you want to grab
more sleep I'm not even tired
great transitions
[Music]
he called her cargo
oh you know come on man
it's tense we can jog right around this
tunnel
take the next ramp
and we're back on the road minute tops
oh boy
let's try to see if anyone's like
watching them
is a highway I can't tell from this I'm
all turned around so don't look at the
state map look at the inside either
there's some car man
I mean I think we're heading north
underworld 2003 Matchstick Men yes
[Music]
I'm gonna help him
oh
no
nicely done okay yeah you're not heard
nothing I don't think so get out
[Music]
just like the game
hey over the off-screen shouting yeah
when I say go you crawl to that wall and
you squeeze through and you don't come
out until I say okay
[Music]
look at me
I'm not gonna hit you
hey John you stay low you stay quiet
[Music]
okay yeah that connection between them
yeah this is intense
oh the crawl
nicely done Joe
[Music]
oh
I'm in the mood for Doritos now yeah
get in there Ellie
[Music]
yes that's what I was thinking
oh okay oh you know what to do
nice
one more no no no no it's okay it's okay
it's over we're not fighting anymore oh
interesting
uh
my mom isn't far if you can get me to
her
finish the job yeah yeah for sure we
could be friends I didn't know
wow
so real
you can have it it's a good night
he's gonna take it anyway
get back behind the wall no no no I'm
sorry I'm sorry please please please
stop please
dude's begging
[Music]
didn't waste the bullet yeah let's just
think of that yeah smart Ellie I gotta
get in there I can't fit through
there's some stuff against the door can
you move it yes
go fast right I really like the way they
changed that scene yeah different
location than in the game beyond that
like just the more Humanity to everybody
yeah yeah
I'm okay I'm good I uh covers up
[Music]
yep
what else do you want me to say I don't
know the truth definitely
ah
you know where Henry has
this is so
where my brother was beaten to death
I got sick I delivered you
think I won't do it I'm your doctor
that's a lot more depth to the hunters
who did this we think it was Outsiders
we found a truck ah Jeffrey Pierce
that's cool
[Music]
I was like Tommy could be mercs will he
live there's
I'm sorry
that's crazy they're humanizing the
hunters yeah imagine everyone
sorry for my excitement guys about
Jeffrey Pierce but I love Miss Tommy
yep there it is
find every collaborator
and Kill Them All
oh my God
[Music]
this is tense I know it's like full on
Military rating yeah
a little bit maybe search for supplies
they'll be coming through these places
soon enough
it was like hiding out during World War
II are you okay
I'm all right
this guard down are you all right oh he
asked her he shouldn't have had to him
when you're just a kid
I don't know what it's like first time
that you heard someone like that
if you uh
hmm
I'm not good at this yeah you really
aren't
I shouldn't have had two
and I'm sorry
they really do work well together man oh
that's perfect casting it wasn't my
first time
mm-hmm
[Music]
you should have mentioned that finger
off the trigger
know who taught you that Central School
figures
there you go
look at
ever thought someone teaching someone
how to hold a gun was so adorable
you put it in your pack
shoot your damn ass off
that's how the season ends she shoots
her [__]
we'll get through this
damn they're good I know amazing amazing
you
I want to see a scene where he talks to
Gabriel Luna yeah it'd be awesome
[Music]
yes love finding stuff like that
he's [__] close I can feel it yeah
what
like these additional layers of the hunt
for Henry and Sam yeah also feels a lot
more personal too there's a reason that
they're hunting for them rather than
it's just random
[Music]
is that what we think it is
is it gonna happen right now I didn't
think it was gonna happen this early
[Music]
wouldn't we tell the others not yet she
said in episode two bomb let's just
handle what we have to handle we can
deal with this after Kathleen after oh
she's blinded by vengeance
seal off the building for now
okay
damn the consequences I'm gonna get
Henry and Sam it's part of The Last of
Us world man yeah
the Joel Ellie boost is that her first
one of the show yeah yeah take a look
around first
encourage you be without me huh
am I now Wyoming oh yeah walked into
that one
[Music]
.
wow this is so scary
oh my goodness
hey you know the guy who said he was
hurt how do you know it was an ambush
I've been on both sides
it was a long time ago we did what we
needed to survive you and test
and the people we were with
a horrible thing
did you kill innocent people
come on
you have to survive yep
oh
33 floors that's good who hasn't been to
the gym in a while
give me a minute
get up you lazy ass
oh I mean yes 56 years old you little
[__]
[Music]
smart smart just don't step on that in
the morning you sure you're gonna hear
it of course I'll hear it that's the
damn point
we were talking about hurting people
what did you mean it wasn't your first
time
I don't want to talk about it
you don't have to
sign okay he's trying to grow an
interest in her and asking her questions
so it gets easier when you get older
no not really you're
really you'd hear the glass or not
because I've noticed you don't hear Too
Well from your right side
is it because you were shot there
probably more from shooting so if you
want to keep your hair and you stick to
that knife
hey I thought it keeps hurting back and
forth to each other push and pull hmm
did you know diarrhea is hereditary
it runs in your jeans
that's a good tension breaker
[Music]
I made him oh I love that that's so
goddamn stupid [__]
Jesus I'm losing it you're losing a big
time
laughs
oh
this is so cute
[Laughter]
oh
I know seriously
he's got the feels I really nailed those
two casting choices
oh [__]
oh damn
foreign
[Music]
that was I'm telling you the pacing of
this [__] through the first four
episodes is unbelievable I'm so bummed I
know like no I want more were yeah I
thought that was uh I thought that was
great I'm really digging the show an
awful lot yes you know like
um it's great tease at the end I I would
like to go into it a little bit but um
yeah I mean even in fact you haven't
played the game I think it's pretty
obvious who those two characters are
right I should hope the audience who
hasn't played the game knows who those
two characters are they kind of mention
them throughout the episode yeah yeah so
uh it's it's it should be pretty
apparent who they are
um but I like the the way they ended off
for an introduction with them here I
think that's really great especially for
non-gamers uh for people now I won't say
non-gamers or for just people who
haven't played the game I think it's
really smart but I mean beyond that like
the the emotional focus and intensity of
this episode I think is so solid you
know like the something that we were
talking about heavy spoilers video is
how a a common thing for a common friend
for actors is the this thing called um
the the prior moment basically like what
is your prior moment before doing a
certain scene so that often affects how
your current scene is going down right
so sometimes in this show what they'll
do is have these
these scenes that are like dialogue wise
word for word but though more than just
change location the prior moment leading
into this scene where there's ripping
straight out the dialogue from a scene
it'll still feel completely different
because it's got a different prior
moment leading into it or a different
placement of when they decide to show
this particular word for word scene like
the scene on the staircase for example
um you know talking about hurting
innocent people and stuff like that and
other moments throughout you know like
the car placement scene was almost like
exactly from the game like at the very
beginning also too in the magazines with
her with him in the game he gets
extremely upset at her when she takes
the gun and shoots the guy well yeah I
mean yeah because that the whole that
whole thing was very different in the
game yeah now that we've gone to that
point like there's this whole sequence
that happened at uh was it a hotel or
this is a hotel yes a little bit after
no it was not a little bit after test
time it was after Bill yeah it was after
the bill was it was around this time it
was just a little further along than
that specific location where they
crashed the car but I love the addition
that they do here because you know like
in the game when she does shoot that guy
it's just some random guy who tried to
drown Bill like it's just ah not Bill
Joel it's some random guy I try to drown
Joel and then here this dude's like
humanizing moment Becky my name's Brian
like please don't and it and it drives
home that point of harsher decisions and
like harsher choices you have to make
for survival and it's it makes it more
heartbreaking because like I'm not
heartbroken for the guy of course but
you know it makes the choice a little
bit harder to adapt to when oh now this
person has a name this person has an
identity this person's crying like it's
it's a whole new ball game when you're
you're dealing with that level of
emotion
yeah it adds a more realistic touch and
even cutting to Ellie you know on her
own private time uh you know shedding a
tear over what just happened was a
little more badass in the in the game
and here you're seeing and that that was
and I like that they did that because I
remember in the game Thinking Ellie
might be a little bit more like what we
actually saw here in the show where she
does get like very like they do have
that conversation that you see but this
is something that I like actually
cutting to the perspective of her
immediate aftermath and the struggle of
what she just dealt with in that moment
you know yeah for sure I mean it's
interesting you say that about the you
know the moment before that happens
because that was literally what I was
thinking you know in terms of that
specific uh moment where you know she
shoots the the guy in the game versus
where she shoots him here and then the
discussion that they have yeah a lot of
the dialogue is very similar but because
of I mean similar situations but
different parts like that whole exchange
happens in the game like immediately
after with you know him getting very mad
at her whereas in this it happens a
short time after because they've gotten
to hide now where you made a great
comparison felt like World War II where
they're hiding from you know soldiers so
I thought that was a great comparison
but um yeah and also too I I think an
interesting touch that they did in this
is in the game for those of you who have
not played we kind of mentioned it
during the reaction the hunters are not
touched upon other than they're just
hunting for whoever is out there and
they just want to kill you there's no
specific reason other than they're just
hunting you so cold-blooded [__]
exactly okay so I actually like the
touch of you know there's no black and
white there is some gray there of you
know these characters are more humanized
now they've got this leader Kathleen
played by Melanie do you remember the
blocky Melanie Linsky from the Two and a
Half Men and uh uh Ever After with Drew
Miramar but I I actually light up right
what she's not at the cave right no no
no
I was like watching it yeah Kathleen is
not a character in the game and again
with the hunters we don't ever see a
leader in in the in the video game so
again I thought that was interesting to
touch the whole Revenge story about two
certain specific or one specific
character that she kept on mentioning
and again it just adds a very humanizing
touch to the character it adds a lot
more layer and depth now when you play
the games like okay no even though in
the it's different contexts of course
but you can play it around in your mind
now but I that's one of the things I
really love about this show is they're
not slaves to the game yes they want to
get some you know visual imagery that
they want to pay respect to yes there
are lines of dialogue they do want to
pay respects to but they they take you
know they they expand upon things we've
mentioned that plenty of times and but
they do it in a very smart and
provocative way and again I just I
really wasn't even thinking like oh yeah
watching the first three episodes
they're definitely going to expand upon
the hunters and give a an in-depth
leader that where I'm gonna feel a
little more like
kind of sympathizing for the leader and
why they're searching for these
characters but at the same time I don't
want them to find the character so it's
like again there's no there's no black
and white there's a gray area in there
so I thought that was a very smart
decision by Craig Mason and uh Neil
druckman and again just really
interesting expanding upon the hunters
and I know I'm sorry I shouted so loudly
uh when we saw Jeffrey Pierce I was just
so excited I wasn't expecting to see him
right there uh but that was so cool that
they got him in there yeah I made the
joke that'd be awesome if we could get
him with Gabriel Luna I want to get Troy
Baker do a scene with Joel want to get
Ashley Johnson do a scene with uh belly
so let's make it happen Neil druckman I
know the show's been shot but just
re-edit go back
it would be neat I'm finding myself on a
on the experience of this is is
interesting because I'm finding myself
like there there are so many times where
I'm like that is from the game but uh
before in like the first couple episodes
I'd be like this is true from the game
like I'll be freaking out but now I'm
like I'm so immersed in the show
that I'm just like having a kind of a
quiet acknowledgment in my head I'm like
that that is in the game but I'm I've
just adapted so much to this new version
that it's just kind of cool to take it
on it's I'm really finding myself taking
in more on its own now more than ever
versus just constantly thinking so much
about the game even when I'm reminded of
scenes of like oh yeah I remember this
line of this is this exchange and stuff
like that because they the way the the
the Friendship is the kinship I would
say more so the kinship between Ellie
and Joel is developing
while similar it feels different yeah
there's there's more of a
off-beat pairing about the two of them
you know in this one yet the chemistry
and the Coalition of them still it still
gels very much it still gels very well
yet though I think like physically
there's just something about the way
that they look that makes them a little
bit more of an oddball pairing
but that makes it more Charming to me
versus the because like but what I mean
by that is if if you were to just show
me the cover of The Last of Us game and
you showed me Joel and Ellie and you
said they were father and daughter I'd
be like okay like they would look like
they look like their father and daughter
right we're here you get you really get
the sense of strangers who are forming a
kinship here
and I like that kind of odd pairing
between them it makes it it drives home
that character development even more and
having these like things with the
riddles and the little jokes that
they're making and the puns yeah the
puns and when to put when to place them
at riddles
was the hottest hardcore riddles but the
placements of of of those scenes and
like having the camping moments and um
watch watching in the private time of
his protection for her growing and I I
love the scene when he is
struggling to
connect with her and open up they'd be
like hey are you all he needs to be like
is are you okay and it's cool watching
Pedro Pascal do it because we've seen
him do so many performances and to see
him play a guy who has like an actor's
job is to connect and people in her
bullets to see a guy really like be such
a believable version of someone who
can't do that is uh is really uh it's
intriguing to me on a lot of levels
there was one thing specifically I
mentioned if all else fails there's one
thing they have this was during our
trailer reaction uh the final Trail
reaction of this show if all else fails
there's one thing they have to nail on
the show and that's the relationship and
the chemistry between Joel and Ellie and
so far through four episodes
I mean Hook Line and Sinker it's been
absolutely beautiful it's endearing it's
adorable yeah there are some you made
really good analysis on some differences
from the game to uh what we've we're
seeing on the show in spirit I feel a
lot of similarities but yes I agree with
what you're you're saying but I mean
there's just so many little character
moments that I just deeply appreciate
and I'm just getting so emotional I mean
obviously I'm emotionally connected with
these characters in the game obviously
but I'm I'm talking just straight up
from the show the chemistry that these
two actors have with each other with
belly and with Pedro Pascal is just
unbelievable they just the Rapport they
have you just instantly get at least for
me you just instantly get connected with
these two characters I just really love
watching them I think my favorite part
too yes it's it's the softer more
vulnerable moments I that I deeply
appreciate those are probably some of my
favorite moments but I love when they
bag on each other like there's just
something so in there's something so
cute and endearing about that and also
too as I pointed out when he was
teaching showing her how to use the gun
like again I normally wouldn't say that
that's cute but that was really that was
really adorable I just again just
everything they do it just gets me more
emotionally attached to these two
characters and they're both just doing
such a wonderful job I know everyone
when belly was originally cast like she
doesn't look like Ellie now granted I
had never seen Game of Thrones I heard
she does a phenomenal job on that show
but
I mean to me she's just doing such an
amazing job as as Ellie she's just like
again she's got that bad out that badass
Persona in that smart mouth but the
chemistry that she invokes with Pedro
Pascal it's just it's really beautiful
to watch they're so electric together on
screen and it's just really it's really
beautiful to watch it's so endearing so
I I really I really love what they're
doing with each other the Rapport that
they have with each other it's just it's
it's it's really sweet well yeah I'm
really taking it I find myself comparing
way less and just taking the show on its
own merits as time goes on and I love I
love that experience and I think episode
three really helps set yeah yeah the
play the playing field for that good
good point like because episode three is
so different that I'm it is easier to
kind of just take whatever I'm getting
now on like just what is the show doing
and just leave it at that you know and
because like you know Pedro Pascal's
version of Joel
feels very different to me than Troy
Baker's and it's cool to have Bella
Ramsay here whose version feels very
akin to Ashley Johnson to Ashley Johnson
feels so akin to it yet doesn't feel
like she's playing Ellie it feels like
she's
not so pretentious to say it sounds like
it sounds like she's being Ellie you
know and and I I love that you kind of
you got one that feels very
in a lot of ways very accurate to the
game and then one that feels like
they're they are doing their own thing
but both feel very natural and nuanced
and lived in and uh yeah I'm really
falling for the the the the the tone of
it and so much of the character
development of these two seems to be in
a lot of just moments of quiet like
Quiet Moments yeah uh private moments
moments where you this exchange of looks
and not like big dialogue scene like the
dialogue's important but so much of the
character development and and the
understanding of them seems to just be
in the body language and in the eyes oh
for sure and and again like the the
private moments I I think that's really
neat like to have a moment like where
Ellie's Crying by herself
and then if you
and then the next scene when she's with
Joel it's it's like she wasn't crying
she doesn't even play it like she's
covering up you know what I mean like
you would if they deleted the whole
thing of her crying you would not have
thought for a second that she's covering
up tears and I think that makes it even
more real because it's a real version of
covering up yeah no and just adding on
to what you say too like that that one
of the last scenes that we saw there
were Joel just thought that that pun
joke was just so stupid and you see him
finally smiling letting his guard down
and you just kind of see that Humanity
starting to come back towards Joel and
that love that he felt the love he had
for Sarah and the Beloved protection and
now it's you know that he feels that way
towards Ellie it's just really
blossoming really nicely so yes I love
it and granted We're not gonna talk
about what we think was underground that
was starting to come up
um although Gamers you probably know it
that's exactly what the [__] you know
what's coming off yeah you know it's you
know it's coming but I think like one
thing I did appreciate about that moment
with Kathleen
is she's so blinded by Revenge which
again I can't go into spoiler territory
about future events not in the first
game
um I just think it's an interesting
theme again being so blinded by Revenge
to get you know to get your target that
you're gonna sacrifice everything else
and you know lose your Humanity over it
it's an interesting you know theme to
come by and just to see that again I
like when they play around with that I
think it's very interesting so I'm yeah
I again I just didn't expect to get so
many different layers there with the
hunters I just that was just I should
have thought about that you know with
how what they did in episode three and
what how much they've expanded just in
general with the first two episodes but
that's why this show is so smart I'm
like I don't give any damn cams about
the hunters in in the game like shoot
and kill them all but like here it's
again while I of course want them to
defend themselves I don't want you know
Joel Ellie and
the two characters we saw at the end
together of course I don't want any of
them to get hurt of course not but again
just when you humanize and give us an
emotional connection to these characters
and a relatability it's like
damn Neil and Craig very nice touch
because I hated I hated these [__]
in the game like I wanted them to die so
bad well that's the cool part about it
is this the while there's you know like
in that whole thing with uh when the
truck gets smashed and then they they
fight the hunters and stuff like while
there's like some good visual motifs
that make you that hearken back to the
gameplay of that moment what I like
about what this show does so well is
that it doesn't feel like they're just
trying to recapture what the gameplay
looks like they're they really drive
home the the humanity and the violence
like the violence hits and they they
more go so go for the emotion that the
characters must be experiencing in this
moment more than let's do a cool visual
Recreation of the gameplay of because
there's there's a scenario where you
could do that that's what most video
game adaptations would attempt to do and
really fail at it and then here they
they don't even seem bothered by it
while there's like little parts for the
most part I'm not like oh damn they're
doing that thing it looks like just a
cool moment from when you're playing in
the game it's and I I like that they
lean more into they keep it all
thematically and emotionally based and
even even in these scenes where they
could just easily go let's recreate what
the gameplay is like yeah for sure and
it's also interesting too in the last
two episodes we barely I mean obviously
in this episode we didn't really see any
in fact I don't think we saw any
infected in the last episode oh I mean
it's a big part of Last of Us is mammers
man yeah no no of course but I I'm my
point is that that's why I try and tell
people who have never played the game
like yes there are zombies are infected
whatever you want to say yes they are in
there but they're really a backdrop part
of the game they're not it's not a it's
not a zombie infected type of game where
that's the main focus like that's just
it's a part of the world but that's what
Primal survival humanity is what this
show is about as the world is is uh is
about yeah yeah but I think they're
doing a great job of like you know
taking a little break from the infected
on a couple episodes and then you know
getting into the humanity of this
character is fleshing out these
characters you know showing us the
survival of the fittest moments and all
that stuff so I and again just the stuff
they're doing with Ellie and Joel is I
really love these two actors so much
they're just so they're great so great
together so I'm I and also too I
mentioned this right right at the start
of the review this show
I know we're only four episodes in again
this is through four episodes this is
one of the best paced shows I've ever
seen it's really well placed it's really
low there's never moments where I'm like
even on the last episode what was it
like an hour and 15 but whatever it was
I was like I'm even when they go slow
burn when they go actually I'm never
like this is really dragging it's really
off balance with with the the pa the
pacing is really not there they're
always right and again that's not it for
someone who has like watched other
people and know people who work in the
film industry it's not an easy thing to
to bounce and get something well paced
it's very hard actually and through four
episodes Absolutely they've nailed in my
opinion they're executing the [__] out
of this and I'm loving it yeah
all right guys what'd you think about
this episode leave your thoughts down
below
um look out for John and Tara's reaction
and you can follow Andrew on Twitter
thank you guys so much for hanging out
with us especially if you made it this
far in the video please subscribe if you
haven't done so and we will talk with
you all soon thank you for being here
[Music]